in books and movies they are monsters of
the deep with massive jaws waiting to
trap an unwary diver and drag them to
their doom true to their name giant
clams are the largest of their kind with
shells over 4 feet long but they're
hardly dangerous in fact there's never
been a reported death by clam life as a
giant clam is rather peaceful they live
in coral reefs in the warm shallow
waters of the Pacific Ocean with shells
wide open they bask in the sunlight each
clam has a set of unique colored
patterns on its skin just under its skin
is its silent partner an algae colony in
this symbiotic relationship the clam
provides the LG with protection in
exchange for skimming a little algae off
the top for the midnight snack never one
to pass up a free meal the giant clams
also filter feed on plankton using their
siphons to draw water in and out over
their gills but they don't want to
become food themselves scattered across
their skin are hundreds of tiny eyes
with them it can sense shadows overhead
any sudden change and the clam is closed
for business although never fast enough
to put a person out of commission in
fact the way most people are hurt by
giant clams is by trying to pick them up
they can weigh a monstrous 500 pounds